hello
my name is paul polenko my co-presenter
is charles poo
we are developers at wolfram research
and our presentation
is entitled connecting to the wolfram
computational geometry engine
wolfram engine connects to a lot right
now
um and and that's one of the things that
we're really going to focus on
is the extent that we connect
to now and when i say we connect
to something what i'm saying is they
have an interface that we also
implement and we can establish
communication to do things
later in this presentation i'm going to
show you a specific example of that
in an application called blender we're
going to show you how
mathematica out of the box can
communicate with blender out of the box
just a couple minutes first we're going
to talk about the
how this occurs and all the different
ways that we
can communicate
why we use different ones for different
reasons
so what we have is evaluating external
languages languages like python
nodejs julia
and what we can do is basically evaluate
external function calls
passing simple parameters uh integers
strings
things of that nature reasonably low
level not a lot of structure
in the data running arbitrary processes
starting processes running processes um
to obtain process level parallelism
application level parallels
essentially on most modern cpus uh
generating code uh to call from language
function
functions um embedded code and a lot of
your modern web languages
uh support embedded code and then c
c plus java.net
python um and this
group right here
basically encompasses uh a
vast array of modern modern applications
most modern applications implement one
of these
one or more of these and almost every
modern application
that does anything a serious amount of
application
implements something here to be able to
con to
right now connect to wolfram engine so
our uh import and export formats just an
overwhelming variety and different
categories within
that variety of file important exports
within these certain formats um
web deployment cloud deployment network
programming
socket connect real low level uh
general programming and that will
actually implement this in
call to blender so those are just a
real quick uh look at
some of the ways that we
do connect to two applications now
so we're gonna zoom in on one of those
and take a closer look and that's python
so basically the point is that any
digital content creator dcc that
implements python can interface
with the wolfram engine now and we're
going to show an example of
exactly that but before we do we want to
talk about tighter integration
so this this is where we kind of bring
it together
and the example that we're going to use
is unity link and
unity link integrates wolfram engine
more tightly with unity
we basically connect to virtually
everything now including unity
but what unity like does is it provides
a tighter integration so let's go ahead
and take a look at the
the unity link page and we're gonna
we're gonna go and
talk about the the basics over here but
before we do this is
this is a lot more familiar to a lot of
people particularly people who
have a mathematical background exported
graphics is really what i want to point
to
um anyone who's ever programmed
any reasonable mathematica understands
that graphics
and graphics object can be arbitrarily
complex
okay so there's a lot of structure
that's not just a simple uh
integer array or a string there's a
there's a lot of structure involved in
in moving that so that's that's one of
the things i wanted to point out just
because it's such an easy
easy uh example to understand so let's
let's look a little closer
at uh at unity link and what we can see
is
we see low level to high level all the
way to scene and then a game object and
what's a game object um it's a
collection
of components uh audio source transform
um a mesh render okay and a mesh is
basically anything that's rendered in a
3d scene
uh for for our sake and purposes right
now
uh lights cameras uh mesh filters
basically everything you need to render
a 3d model
and then take a collection of 3d models
and render them into a scene as people
would do
typically want to do in unity and so
we provide the mechanisms to seamlessly
do things at that high level
with unity learning so that shows you
that
that we're taking low level calls and
we're
we're building them into uh things that
are that are more substantive
higher level control and and are much
more tightly integrated
so let's go ahead and take a look
um at something that we can connect to
now and are going to
and that's blender and blender is a
popular dcc digital content creator used
to
create 3d models photorealistic images
movies
and more so let's go ahead and take a
look at uh blender website
and you can go to one it's free to
download blender and the blender i'm
using is
just a regular download you can see
about the cycles rendering engine you
can see the kind of
uh images that it generates scripting
uv textures vfx integrating with
video and 3d models animation
rigging um story our 2d 3d
all kinds of stuff and this is really
kind of brings us full circle make your
own where
blender has a flexible python control
interface
and so we say well if it has a python
interface
we should be able to to integrate with
so let's
show that we can and what we have is
blender right out of the box nothing
[Music]
nothing
added straight into the scripting
language and we'll
open up a new script and now we're just
going to paste something in there so
i'm going to go over here and we
previously prepared some
python make sure we get the right file
and we're just going to select it all
copy it right over here
into blender
come up here and run it
open up mathematica in 12-1
make the socket connect call and it's
turning about and it connects
because blender is waiting for it and
now we're just gonna
send this string over and this program
is going to
add a cube over there
and there it is and then it's gonna
do no command to show that it recognizes
that it's no
no command we're gonna send an axis and
it
sends the axis over there and we're
gonna quit
and we just control blender through
mathematica and
notice this can be anything this is this
exposes
the entirety of the blender api
so this is a simple contrived example
but it could be anything one other thing
i do want to show
is another simple example but kind of
uh to the point of extending their their
gui also
while we're here just as easy another
program
uh python programs like the whole thing
copy
bring it over here
remove the existing program
and paste the new one in and then run it
and look you see
item tool view and now you're going to
see another tab get added
and it's the mathematica tab and now we
have our own tab and
kind of brought a full circle where we
can connect the buttons to the
functionality so
it's basically what we wanted to show
how how easy this
is to to do all these things
so really this this is the message that
we're trying to depict
is uh connect between the wolfram engine
and the digital content creators we got
you know maya unity blender we already
talked about houdini 3d max and
and we can connect to them through a
variety of
application interfaces right now just
like we did with blender
in the future we want to make things
more like unity like so we can make
things
easier for the people who are trying to
to use our software
uh to help in their workload and to do
the things at a higher level that
they're looking to do
so that's the direction that we're
looking to go that's the vision
that's the presentation and i hope you
enjoyed it
hope it was informative and thank you
very much
for listening uh feel free to
turn on your microphone if you have any
question
so i'm here i'm charles and
paul is also here to answer your
question
hello hello
i had a question about uh
either exporting or
print out 3d uh to to stereo lithography
is this the right place to be asking the
question
um yes definitely the right place yes
okay um so
if i uh using 12 1
uh i create a solid that's a combination
of
of cubes and spheres
and those render fine
but then i add an ellipsoid
under them and essentially they all sit
on the tubes and spheres um
and the
as soon as i had the ellipsoid
the the rendering
the rendering fails so they gave me
i posted this on on stack exchange
and they gave me a workaround and a
workaround
works only for ellipsoids it doesn't
work for prisons but
um um
essentially if i if i let me open let me
open our link in
zoom so i can i can give you the link
uh how do i just switch to zoom oh here
it is i have a button for zoom hold on i
don't know i
maybe i'll go away i'll be back on soon
hold on
i typed a couple questions into the chat
there um
under michael trot there um so
concerning the blender call
was that interesting there um can you go
the other way can you have
blender call wolfram
um yes so the the plan is to build a
bidirectional link
right so that uh essentially if you are
a world farm user more familiar with
wolfram you can use blender and all the
advantages which come with blender
but on the other side if you are you
know a blender user and you just want to
use some functionality in the welcome
language
it should be just you know from blender
just called the welcome language for
example you can generate a geometry
or do some you know manipulation on your
scene
directly from the world from language
and i believe during the presentation uh
paul actually shows that
and it will be kind of model based on
the you know the unity link
so it's a pure directional you know
bi-directional link on the live link
actually between both systems
so what we hope is essentially you know
if you're a blender user you and your
blender interface and editor you can
just use the word form engine behind
like a plugin
pretty much
i hope that answers your question
yep also a more technical question is uh
what about using godot instead of unity
i don't know if that means anything to
you guys but
um i'm not familiar with the door what
is it a game engine is it uh basically i
think the problem with unity is it has
some interesting licensing things that
makes it a little bit awkward to use
um but godot is more of a it's a more
open
system than unity but it also works in
blender
it doesn't work in blender oh did they
they play nicely together they play
nicely together
sorry i'm translating for uh my wife who
is a big blender user so
oh okay well we'll take a look at it
and uh i'm not familiar with that and
i'm sure we can
probably just later on you know sit down
and look more in detail
right i might have to have some
pre-scripted questions because uh
like i said i'm kind of a middleman here
so
that's that's perfect as long as we get
all the questions and feedback from the
expert you know
you blend the user that would be great
right
thanks welcome
um and nicolas had the question he
actually sent
on the on the chat there which was the
link and i think his original question
was essentially trying to export
a
you know to use 3d print sorry
print out 3d function to generate you
know stl
or
directly from our geometry so
essentially he was using
um
cube from what i read from stack
exchange
and when he added an ellipsoid you have
issues
um
i am not sure i understand the
issue from
the stack exchange post but
but i will just kind of talk more in
general on the pipeline so
in principle when you have uh you know
graphics
right like uh you know tube
ellipsoids which are all kind of roughly
quadratic surfaces
right ldls just support polygon
so what we do behind the scene is first
to discretize them
so we often approximate them with you
know polygonal surfaces
with polygons so we get the polygonal
surfaces and export them
so the only time where that you know the
issue can happen
is during that conversion right
and what we also try to do is that right
so when you have a scene
and you have you know different objects
in the scene so we are not really sure
that you are exporting
your function you know i mean you are
seeing when you exporting it we don't
really know how
you know what you are going to do after
so in between we try to do some boolean
operation
to essentially you know found a high
quality
you know mesh mesh region at the end and
that also may be the issue
especially that for 3d printing you
don't actually really need to do the
boolean operation usually the union when
you have a big scene
right you don't really need to actually
join all the elements
all together right and do the the
boolean operation before you send it to
the 3d printer
because the slides will actually take
care of it
so what i will suggest in your case is
that when you have an issue like that
you should just discretize all the
elements
have them in the graphic and then use
export
directly so through that pipeline we're
actually
going to avoid doing a boolean operation
and you should be able to actually
always get your object correctly
so the geometry will have overlapping
polygons
and you know your slider slicer or your
3d printer will take care of it because
it doesn't really matter for it when it
slides the geometric object if there is
there is self-intersection and this
should actually work in principle
so i hope that kind of you know kind of
gave you an idea of you know where the
issue may happen
and what you know
how to work around it
and nicolas actually here i hope that
answer your question
so feel free to yeah the
the it answers the question it gives me
a workaround
for the ellipsoid adding the ellipsoid
uh but but the the
it doesn't i don't think it gives me the
answer for the prisms
which doesn't matter because i was
trying to substitute the prisms for the
ellipsoid in case
in case i could print out 3d the prisms
but but exporting it's exporting the
graphic where the ellipsoid is fine
for the ellipsoids is fine um but
just just looking forward i suppose my
my advice would be that that i don't
understand
why i should disc how to discretize the
graphics
um before before exporting them and 3d
printing them
um yeah so the
the in principle the peace should work
right if there is an issue send me that
i mean that one should be a trivial case
um i was this i was explaining why we
need to discretize it because an
ellipsoid right
is a quadratic surface a smooth surface
right in principle you cannot actually
represent it
you know preserve the fidelity by
representing it as an scl5
because scl just represent polygons
you see so what we do is that we need to
approximate that surface
with polygons right
then the prism should should should
be easy to represent because the prism
is
polygons right exactly so that's why
that one i
you know i'm pretty much convinced that
you should work automatically if it
doesn't work that mean
it's a bug and this is you know it'd be
surprising that
such a bug because no prism is just
purely
being yourself so that should be trivial
yeah so i know just you know if you have
any issue you know feel free to
you know send me an email with charles p
goldfarm.com and you know we can
take a look at it and you know try to
suggest a workaround
or hopefully things will work easier for
you
well if there is not uh there is no
other question um
it's already 11 we are going to close
this talk
thank you for attending and watching the
video
you